ladies and gentlemen and welcome to the  design education summit 2018 the summit  brings together educators and industry  professionals inspiring you with the  value of design  [Music]  design is a strategic tool and industry  that can help propel the competitiveness  of our companies and our economy to new  heights  [Applause]  [Music]  it's critical for us then to start  investigating into the insights into  what are the ways in which consumers  perceive relevancy to a brand to a  product and we wanted to examine that  from not just functional but to  emotional as well as through social  needs  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  designers are keen on not just the  outcome but very much of how do you go  about you have to try out many things  and many things don't work and actually  it's the only way to learn  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  it's been a great honor being here for  the inaugural design education summit  2018 we'll see you at the next event  soon  you